العدسات اللاصقه المنتج المستهلك بقوه
والمطلوب دائما من قبل الملايين حول العام
العالم اما طبعا لغرض طبي او تجميلي خبر
صادم لمستخدمي العدسات مختبر طبي معتمد في
الولايات المتحده توصل الى وجود مواد
مسرطنه في 18 علامه تجاريه شهيره من
العدسات طبعا مضمون دراسه مشاهدينا توصل
الى انه العديد من العدسات اللاصقات تصنع
من مواد كيماويه ابديه تدخل وتستقر في
العين ولا تتحلل بسهوله ابدا ولذا هي
ابديه بل وكميات اعلى بخمسين الف مره من
المستويات التي تعتبر امنه
وتلك التي قد تسبب مع مرور الزمن مشكلات
صحيه بما في ذلك السرطان ايضا امراض الكبد
الكلى اضافه الى اضطرابات المناعه الذاتيه
ومشاكل الخصوبه المزيد حول انواع هذه
العدسات المستهلكه وطريقه استخدامها دائما
مع الزميله لميس لميس صباح الخير صباح
الورد
تطورت العدسات على مدى التاريخ وتتابع
التحسينات عليها وصنفت بانواع على حسب
الاستخدام والحاجه اولها العدسات اليوميه
والتي يتم ارتدائها مره واحده ثم التخلص
منها توفر اعلى مستوى من الراحه فلا تحتاج
للتنظيف او التخزين مناسبه لمن يعانون من
حساسيه العيون العدسات الشهريه والنصف
اسبوعية تستبدل وفقا لجدول زمنيا منتظم
طلب التنظيف والتخزين عاده وتصل مده
الموصل لارتدائها من 8 الى 12 ساعه يوميا
هل عدسات التي يمكن ارتدائها لفترات طويله
بما في ذلك اثناء النوم وهي مصنوعه من
مواد تسمح للوصول كميه كافيه من الاكسجين
الى القرنيه
[موسيقى]
ما ادري ليش جبالي عبد الحليم حافظ العيون
السود
في طب العيون الدكتور علي فضل الله دكتور
صباح الخير والله العيون السود حلوه او
حتى كانت الطبيعيه احنا والله دائما افضل
دائما الطبيعي افضل دكتور يعني هذا خبر
صادم بانه العدسات قد تسبب امراض حتى يعني
العدسات الطبيه ايضا صح هي فعليا العدسات
الطبيه هي المشكله فيها كانت طبيه او كانت
ملونه هذا اللي للاسف كما قلت برهن العلم
انه في ممكن يكون الها مدار على المدى
الطويل
ومدارها ما كنا مكتشفينه قبل وحاليا صار
في هاي الدراسه في جريده الجارديان لبرهنت
انه هناك ماده اسمها الفيورين تستعمل
وممكن تسبب هذه الامراض على المضى الطويل
دكتور كل العدسات اللاصقه يعني من كل
الماركات فيها هاي الماده لانه معروف بانه
هاي العدسات مصنوعه مواد حيويه يتقبلها
الجسم مثل السيليكون مثلا صحي مصنوعه من
السيليكون والهيدروجين اللي هم مواد
طبيعيه جدا بس يتم الاضافه للسيليكون
والهيدروجين الماده اسمها فليوريين هدفها
تخلي هذه العدسه تكون سوفت او لينه على
العين بما انه هذه الماده ضروريه تضاف الى
كل انواع العدسات ان كانت ملونه او غير
ملونه كل الماركات
تستعمل
وبالدراسه اجريت على 18 نوع من انواع
العدسات وتبين انه بكل هالانواع الموجوده
في السوق حاليا موجوده هذه الماده
الفليورين والفلورين ممكن يمتصها جسم او
تمتصها العين طبعا مش من لبسها مره او خمس
مرات انه تعمل اضرار
اي العدسات افضل هل هي التي تغير بشكل
يومي هي التي تستمر اسبوعيا ام شهريا هلا
طبعا التي تستعمل يوميا هي الافضل من
الاسبوعين افضل من الشهري اقل اقل مخاطر
اقل مخاطر بس بالنسبه لماده للاسف موجوده
بثلاثه انواع ان كانت يوميه او ان كانت
اسبوعيه او ان كانت شهريه اليوميه هي افضل
بالنسبه للالتهابات انما تشكل الالتهابات
على العيون التهابات بكتيريه انما
الفيوريين موجود بهذه ثلاث انواع ومن هون
النصيحه انه تخفيض الوقت اللبس بالنسبه
للعدسات ما نكون عم نلبسها مثلا ننام فيها
مثلا نام بعدسه اكبر خطا هذا شيء جدا سيء
يعني بكفي انه نشيلها مثلا بالليل بنكون
خفضنا على الاقل عشر ساعات في اليوم رقم
اثنين نلبسها فقط عند المناسبات الضروريه
ورقم ثلاثه نتكلم انه ممكن ناخذ اتجاه اخر
انه النظاره هلا طبعا النظاره ممكن اشخاص
يقول لك انا ما تناسبني وخاصه بطبيعه عملي
كان مقدم برامج او كان بالعكس
مقدم برامج الحياه سعيده بس نقدر نشوفه
بتكون افضل كمان
التقنيات الليزك تصحيح النظر الي هي صارت
حاليا اامن من العدسات بمئه مره لانه نسبه
الالتهابات مثلا في العدسات واحد بالمئه
في الليزك وواحد من عشره الاف كنا عم
نتكلم عن الطائرات
حاليا يعني ممكن تخسر نظر غير موجود مثلا
يعني فينا نروح على امور اامن اطول ما
نضطر نلبس عدسات دائمه مثل ما قلنا اول
نظره اذا ما حبينا النظاره هي تقنيات
تصحيح النظر بالليزك والليزر دكتور عوده
لهذه الماده اللي ممكن تكون مسرطنه واللي
موجوده في كل العدسات هل يعني حقيقه واقعه
اذا بنستعمل العدسات لهذا الوقت الطويل
لسنين
اكيد راح تضرنا
كلا لانه لا يوجد حاليا دراسات واخذنا الف
شخص لابسين عدسات وقارناهم على الالف شخص
غير لابسين عدسات لنشوف اذا في فروض وعلى
مدى سنين على مدى سنين هي احتمال وهذا
الاحتمال بما انه موجود احنا مش هدفنا
نعمل خوف عند الناس الهدف هو الحذر الحذر
انه انا خليني اخفف من لبس العدسات ما
اكون عم بلبسهم فترات طويله واذا عندي
الامكانيه اني اروح على حلول بديله خليني
اروح على حلول بديله لان الحلول بديله
اكيد اامن من العدسه هل ايضا المواد
الاخرى التي تستخدم حتى نطري هذه العدسه
ايضا قد تسبب لنا او تساعد في في ذلك
السيليكون والهيدروجين الموجودين حتى في
الجسم لا يشكلون ضرر الماده الوحيده هي
الفيوريين وحاليا وشيء جيد طلع تقريبا من
الاف دي اي منظمه الصحه الامريكيه انه يجب
ازاله هذه الماده لحديث العام 2030 يعني
بعد 2030 لا يسمح باستعمالها احنا انتهى
وقتنا اسالك بعجاله شو يعني هل الافضل انه
نتجه للعدسات الصلبه اكثر العدسات الصلبه
ممكن ما تكون تحتوي على الفيورين بس
مشكلتها انها صعبه اللبس جدا هذا المشكل
شكرا جزيلا
لك البروفيسور في طب العيون الدكتور علي
فضل الله كان معنا في الاستوديو شكرا شكرا
جزيلا شكرا لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات